guido maria kretschmer und michelle
hunziker zusammen mit motsi mabuse das
dreamteam der neuen rtl show sechs
promis verstecken sich unter der maske
und führen die songs ihrer lieblings
stars auf der bühne auf und sie müssen
raten wer sich darunter versteckt und
wir sind uns tatsächlich in diesem
ganzen jahren nie begegnet und ich habe
sofort guido gesagt dass ich so hätten
endlich kennenzulernen ich war und bin
ganz großer fan von liebe und ja und
dann hat auch sowas sofort liebe auf
ersten blick ich war auch erstaunt wie
im navi und so schnell waren es war ein
großes glück fand ich mit mit ihm auch
die zeit verbringen
zum ersten mal nach dem krone lockdown
durften bei der show 100 zuschauer dabei
sein
das tv duo hat bild erzählt wie sie die
pandemie erlebt haben ich habe das
gefühl das war wie so ein kleiner urlaub
in meinem leben ich kannte das ja nicht
dass man so dienstag ein feuer dienstag
nicht woche schon wieder so ungefähr das
fand ich immer toll und ich habe
meistens schlechte gewissen am anfang an
dabei brauchte ich wochen bis ich merkte
dass ist alle machen das ist krank
ich habe meinen job nonnenberg am ort
verbracht das ist die staatslinie zweien
meisten gelitten hat und bei uns war das
ja so dass es die ersten zwei wochen
waren lockdown und man dachte dass wir
nur zwei wochen aber es wurde immer
schlimmer und schlimmer und ich hatte
das glück dass ich meine ganze familie
bahn hier hatte ich hatte meine drei
töchter
wenn auch ohne mann und die ganze
familie arbeit dabei aber es gab auch
momente wo will ich auch nicht schlafen
konnten weil wir hat mir eben ganz viele
probleme viele leute die gestorben sind
bei um den welt gang und wir hörten dann
jede minute den krankenwagen und und
auch eben habt dann vor unserem haus die
leichen die dann weg transportiert
wurden und das war hat man hatte
wirklich das gefühl das wäre eine
apokalypse und ich glaube die leute
haben sich alle ein bisschen verändert
auch heute also wir sind alle ein
bisschen anders geworden und nicht nur
im negativen sinn sondern auch im
positiven sinn
heute abend geht die show los rateteam
und zuschauer müssen dann herausfinden
wer ist der star im star
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schaue ich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren